I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi, you guys.
I just want to say I am so happy to be sitting across this recording booth table. Is it a... It's a table? Table? Yeah. From my best friend this morning. Thanks, lady. Yeah.
I am super peppy this morning. That's awesome. I'm really peppy and I got no sleep, which means I'm more loopy than peppy, so buckle in. What is in store for us today? I don't know. Would you like an update on my contrast showers before we begin today? Yeah.
I've taken them to a new level. I don't shower anymore. I'm sorry, what? Well, I mean, I shower for cleanliness, obviously. My way of doing the contrast hydrotherapy shower is now I sit in the hot tub and it's super hot and then I do a cold dip in our freezing cold swimming pool. Why, Jenna? It is so cold.
I am on fire about it. You know what? This is unlocking something in me. I am like, I'm starting to read books about it. Wait, does this mean Office Ladies is going to go somewhere like really icy and do a polar bear plunge? Are we going to Finland? Are we going to have a shot of like some kind of alcohol and then jump in an icy lake?
I don't know if I'm at icy lake yet. I mean, I'm at pretty cold. Would you do it though? No. I don't think. Lee is really into it. Lee wants to talk to Josh about it because Josh, you know, is a super healthy guy. I think he's going to get Josh to start doing it.
Lee and I think maybe 2022 we might get you to do it, Ange. No way. I hate being cold. I want it to be something that you do. No. I don't know why. I don't want to do it. All right, fine.
I would do it on a vacation. I am vacation adventurous. I am not day-to-day adventurous. All right. Take me, you know, somewhere Nordic, maybe I'll jump in and holler after I've had a shot of something. Okay. It's probably not the health routine you want.
Well, today we are going to talk about the meeting, which is season six, episode two. It is written by one of our favorite people, Aaron Schur. Love him. And directed by one of our other favorite people, Randall Einhorn. Yeah. So here's a summary. Jim meets with David Wallace about a possible promotion, Dwight and Toby joined forces to investigate whether Daryl submitted a fraudulent medical claim, and Pam works to lock down
her RSVPs for her and Jim's wedding. I found that storyline so relatable. Well, you just RSVP people, just RSVP. When Meredith says, I'll just text you the day of the wedding, I mean, did you get texts on the day of your wedding because I did? Yeah. I was like, you may not be my friend anymore, person who texted me on my wedding morning to ask me about, like, parking instructions.
I got to text the morning of my wedding about, would this outfit be appropriate? What's the attire again? Is it real fancy or could I wear something casual? See, now listen, Angie, if you text me the morning of my wedding to ask me a question, that's fine. But you know what? I wouldn't. That's the difference.
BFFs get a pass. BFFs do get a pass, but they also know better. Yeah, text another wedding guest. You know someone who's going? Text your most reliable friend who saved the invitation. Text the friend you know in the wedding party. Yeah. That's their job.
Leave. The bride and groom alone. Okay. We could really go off on that. I mean, listen, clearly, it meant so much to us. We moved it up to the top of the show. Yeah. We didn't even wait to get to that scene.
I know. All right, let's do some fast facts. Fast fact number one, this episode is going to kick off a major story arc for Jim in which he becomes the co-manager of the Scranton Branch. Now this is also going to signal a wardrobe change for Jim. Did you notice? Boo, boo, boo, boo, wardrobe change. Jim wears a jacket instead of his usual shirt and tie.
Not just any jacket, a suit. Yeah. This is going to continue while he is co-manager. I guess jacket means you take things seriously. Look at Pam when she become a salesperson. They're the jacket couple now. We are. We're so cute.
You know how Dwight wore his long sleeves for Charles Minor? Yeah. These are ways that our wardrobe department can really, you know, signal storytelling. I think it's very cool and I wanted to give them a shout out. Love it. Loved our wardrobe department. I loved that fast fact. Thank you, Ange.
Fast fact number two, this episode is a very interesting pairing as part of its B story. This feels like one of those assignments that we've heard about, the taking of the two people, Dwight and Toby. When have we had a Dwight-Toby huge storyline? I can't pick up one. I thought the same thing. They were on a card and they got sent off to the writer's pod. Now this B story was also ranked number seven on Screen Rant's Best B Plots.
Do you know what was number one? No. Dwight's Concussion. Oh, with Pam. Yeah. I did love that one. So incidentally, while Paul Lieberstein was starring in this very popular B story, he was also our sole showrunner for this season, season six.
In season five, he shared that title with Jen Salata, but at this point, Jen was starting to develop some other projects, so she took a step back in season six. She was the consulting producer. She worked three days a week. So Paul, our showrunner, was starring in this episode. I don't know. It just amazes me how he juggled it all. I mean, I feel like he was living there for a bit.
Do you think he ever slept there? I feel like maybe at least once. We should ask him. We should ask. Now, Fast Fact number three, Angela, I am handing over to you. What would you like to tell us? I would like to talk about the deleted scenes for this episode. I am titling this Fast Fact because I guess I titled my Fast Facts.
I'm titling my Fast Fact. Stay with me. Long, the long, long, long. Oh, long, the long, long, long. Should I be titling my Fast Facts? No. I think we're all fine, not to. You guys, this episode was a very long script.
Oh. And a lot of our scripts came in very long, but I just thought this one really highlights how much didn't make it in that was written on the page, and I wanted to share that with you. Okay. It's a little insight, you guys, into the deleted scenes of an episode of The Office. So I was training emails with Randy Cordray, and he said that there was so much material for our episodes that our editor's first cuts were usually about 45 minutes long.
And we had to narrow that down to 21 minutes and 30 seconds to broadcast the show. So they would cut more than half? Exactly. That brings me to this script. Jenna, I looked, the shooting draft was 41 pages. Okay. So it's usually a page equals a minute. We've talked about that before.
Right. So they were going to have to edit out more than half the script. I went to the shooting draft and I read the shooting draft as I watched the episode that was broadcast and there were six talking heads that never made it in, eight full scenes that never made it, and then five scenes were actually extended and longer than what made it onto the screen. And I was trading emails with Randy and he brought up a great, great note, which is the whole Dwight and Toby runner, as well as some of the Michael Andy runner really had to be
cut for this episode. And there are elements that didn't make it in that would have really kind of explained a little bit more what was happening. And I'm going to share some of those as we go. Wow. This episode was almost like two A stories to me. Yes. Exactly.
Exactly. But if you think about it, I mean, six talking heads, eight whole scenes, eight whole scenes. Wow. Right? Yeah. But you're going to give us the dish. I'm going to give you the dish. You're going to spill the tea.
Is that what it is? Spill the tea? Do you spill the tea? I think you spill the tea and you serve the dish and you give the scoop. What else? What's another one? I don't know. That's my fast fact.
That just shows you what we had to do every week to trim it to network broadcast. I enjoyed this top of show. And we go to a break and when we come back, we will spill the tea and give the dish and the tell the things. We'll tell all the things. All right. All right. This episode starts with a cold open between Michael and Oscar.
Michael has called Oscar into his office for advice on an upcoming medical procedure. And Oscar is concerned. He's like, Michael, are you okay? What's going on? Michael reveals it's a colonoscopy and wonders if in Oscar's experience, there's anything he can do to make it more pleasurable for himself or the doctor. And Oscar, of course, walks out of Michael's office. Yes.
Now I always love scenes between Steve and Oscar. They are so good together. They're a good comedy duo. This scene made me cringe. Yeah. Oscar's performance is so good. Oh my God. Oscar's amazing.
I caught an improv moment. Oh. Yeah. So it's not in the script. I went to the shooting draft. There's this moment where Oscar says, what's the procedure if you don't mind me asking? And he scooches his chair real close to Michael's desk. Oscar Nunez came up with that sort of physical improv in the moment to sort of, you know,
try to bond with Michael, right? What's happening, Michael? I thought that was just smart acting. Well, Steve and Oscar have a very similar improvisation style, and it's based on small details and slow timing, like patience, pace, all of it. Yeah. Well, I have another background catch in this scene. Okay.
I caught Meredith at front reception talking to Pam, and I couldn't help but wonder, is this a Kate Jenna Fakie spreadsheet conversation moment? You know what, lady? What? She's talking to Erin. Oh no. Yes. Oh my God.
Yeah. And you know what? I saw Kate at reception, and the first thing I thought was, oh my God, or me and Kate doing our bit, and then I realized it's not me. I thought it was me too. Oh my gosh. It's Erin. That just shows you, even though we know the show, we're rewatching it, we were there.
Yeah. And you know what? I saw Kate at reception, and the first thing I thought was, oh my god, or me and Kate doing our bit, and then I realized it's not me. I thought it was me too. Oh my gosh. It's Erin. That just shows you, even though we know the show, we're rewatching it, we were there.
I will always think of Pam as at front reception. It's true. But Pam spends half of the series as not a receptionist, and yet I still think of her as the receptionist, and people regard me as the receptionist when they meet me. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I guess I did. I know.
I did too. Well, as the episode starts, there is a deleted scene, you guys, that would have set up how truly overwhelmed Michael was. And I thought it was kind of important. I want to share it with you. In the shooting draft, it says we're inside Michael's office. Michael is looking slightly more haggard than usual. He sits in his office with Erin.
She is just handing him post-it notes. We see the perimeter of Michael's desktop monitor is completely covered with multi-colored post-it notes. And then Erin says, Bill Seidman from Buffalo, and hands Michael a post-it note. He puts yet another one on his computer. Michael says, thank you. And then Erin hands him another post-it note. And then Erin says, Angela's still waiting for you to approve the new billing rates from
Buffalo. And in the script, it says, Michael lets out an exasperated yelp. He stares at all of the post-it notes. Lady, I have to tell you, at 12 minutes one second, there is a scene between David Wallace and Michael in his office. And in the foreground is half of Michael's computer monitor. And I was like, why are there all these sticky notes on Michael's computer monitor? I took a picture of it to show you.
And here you have answered the question for me. Well, here it is. This is what it looks like in the deleted scenes. I took a picture as well. I'll put it in stories. Oh, that's the full monitor. You have full monitor. I have full monitor.
And you guys, I took a picture of my own desktop computer. Also, is it very similar to Michael Scott's computer? I'm going to put it side by side. Mine is not as bad as Michael's, but clearly Michael and I have the same way of keeping track of things. I have post-its all around my computer, as you know, Jenna, so I couldn't help but crack up. But the scene goes on to sort of explain that Michael is really overwhelmed because of
Buffalo Closing. They've absorbed all the new clients, and it's part of the reason why David Wallace is there. Wow. Well, I feel like that scene would have been very helpful in terms of setup. Yeah. But instead, the episode opens with Michael walking out of his office with David Wallace. And it's just one line.
One line. David is like, can I get the rundown of the Buffalo Clients by Sunday night? Yeah. But you don't know that Michael is like being buried in a sea of post-it notes from all these other new clients. Well, Michael says he will get that rundown done by Sunday night. And David Wallace is like, great. And he's like, well, I mean, I'm going to put it in the mail on Sunday, so you should
get it by Wednesday. But I also thought this can't be an email. You have to physically mail this rundown? Have you seen Michael's computer? Michael's computer is just basically a shelf for post-it notes. True. It's not a working device unless you want to watch a YouTube video. That's all that happens.
Well, now Wallace is going to take Jim into the conference room for a meeting to which Michael is not invited. I have a question for Jim. What? Jim, why, why, why, why would you take this meeting with David? In Scranton. In Scranton. I thought the same thing.
Why not say, David, can I meet you after work? Like can I come to New York? Yeah. Can we have lunch and make up an excuse like clearly everyone else does at Dunderman Flynn, make up an excuse at lunch that you're going to see a client. Of course Michael's going to spiral. Come on, Jim. You know better.
I thought the same thing too, but it was clear that David came to Scranton because he had a lot of business to do. So he's consolidating, but I think Jim should have been more proactive. Well I have a background catch for this little scene. Angela. Give it to me. I love a background catch. At one minute 58 seconds, there is a book on Michael's credenza and it is very prominent
and it is titled First Break All the Rules What the World's Greatest Managers Do Differently. Now I assumed this was a prop book that Phil Shea created. Is it a fakie book? It is a really book. Come on. This is a real book and here is the book's description. In this longtime management bestseller, Gallup presents the remarkable findings of its massive in-depth study of great managers.
Some were in leadership positions. Others were frontline supervisors. Some were in Fortune 500 companies. Others were key players in small entrepreneurial firms. They all excelled at turning each individual employee's talent into high performance. Now according to a review, this study, this analysis, consisted of interviews with 80,000 managers. 80,000?
Yeah. In order to write this book, they talked to 80,000 managers that were determined to be great managers. Wow. Here are three observations from the book, okay? There are many but here's three. Number one, people don't quit their companies, they quit their bosses. No.
True. True. All the jobs I've quit have been because I hated my boss. I mean, I did quit a job just because I hated the job. But your boss was great? Yeah, I liked my boss. Oh. But I hated the job.
Okay. Sorry, it happens guys. Well, number two, one of the signs of a great manager is the ability to describe in detail the unique talent of each employee, what drives them, how they think, and how each one builds relationships. This also sounds like what it is to be a good partner. I mean, that reminded me of what it is to be a great director. Lee is a director, my husband, and he's often said like, you have to have a different directing
style with each actor because some actors like a lot of notes and some don't and some need a lot of pep talk and others hate that. He's like, so like the first day on the job, your job is to figure out just like how to talk to each different person. Like learning everyone's strengths and quirks. Yeah, exactly. And finally, I thought this was very, very interesting. A great manager knows the difference between skills, knowledge, and weakness.
Meaning like just because someone doesn't know how to do something that's not a weakness, maybe that's just a lack of skill or lack of knowledge. But if they have knowledge and they're not doing it right, well, then that would be a weakness. Yeah. So I have to say, I kind of thought that Michael Scott was good at number two and three on the list. Like he really knows everybody really well in his company.
He knows how to motivate them. I thought maybe he had read this book on his credenza. He definitely has number two because the way he introduces a person when someone new is in the office. Yeah. He knows everyone very intimately. He does. It doesn't take Michael long to start spiraling about Jim and David in the conference room.
He says he's not worried, but he corners Pam pretty quickly. He does. He escorts her the three steps to her desk, but she's not telling him anything. She clearly knows why Jim is meeting with David. This scene was so hard to get through, Angela. As soon as Steve would kneel down next to my desk, I would start laughing. Just the sincerity with which he would kneel, but then when he would say that my lies would pass through my breast milk and make my unborn baby a liar, it was like really hard.
It was very, very funny. I really liked it when he said, well, why'd you say good luck? And you were like, that's not like me. I don't know. I'm not sure why I would say that. I'm not very superstitious. I was like, what is Pam doing? She's so bad at lying.
I would like to point out in this scene, I think I'm doing some really wonderful prop work. I am filling a binder with sheets of paper. That was my idea. I thought this would feel like more significant than just carrying some papers from the copier and sitting down. I was like, could you get me a binder and I could be like making a binder? Anything to not be answering his questions.
I liked my choice. I like it too. Well, this is going to start the Dwight Toby runner, aka, are they mom detectives? This whole storyline is 100% a case that mom detectives would take. 100%. Yeah. A fraudulent workers compensation claim. Possible fraudulent.
Possible fraudulent. Dwight is in the break room and he overhears Daryl telling Toby how he broke his ankle and he's got a doctor's note and, you know, Toby's fine with it. And Dwight is like, no, no, no, no, no, red flags, red flags. I'll tell you, the only thing I saw in this scene was a three minutes, 18 seconds. Is it a stuffed animal? The stuffed dog wearing a Toby shirt, wearing a maroon sweater. What the heck?
It totally took me out of the scene for a minute. I was like, where did this stuffed animal come from? Why does it say Toby? What is happening? But wait, just wait, I have a picture that I took, lady, to show you, even though you saw this dog, too. Did you zoom in on it? Just look at it next to Paul.
Just look at it. Come on. Look at Toby dog next to real Toby. Look at it. They are frowning the same, they're in the same color scheme. Look at it. Oh my God. Do you think this is like a writer's joke or Phil Shea joke?
I feel like someone saw this stuffed dog and they were like, oh my God, it's Toby. And they put a Toby shirt on it and then they put it on his desk. Ivy, what is that? I need the story of that. We need to dig deeper. You have to post this picture. It's not in the script. It's not in the script, this Toby dog.
It's all I could see. Well, I guess Dwight brings up enough suspicion that Toby's like, all right, maybe we should check this out, right? And he said, plus, he's always been a fan of these hard-boiled detective novels. Well, we got a fan question from Alice R in Italy who says, around four minutes, 30 seconds, Toby has a sheet behind him that lists all of the HR representatives from all the Dunder Mifflin branches. So besides Toby and Holly, who are these other people?
Are these made-up names? Alice also noted that Holly is wrongly associated with the Utica branch instead of the Nashua branch. She was really looking. I am impressed. I am too. Alice, here's the thing. I zoomed in on this and it was a little fuzzy.
I found it very hard to read and I really looked at it. I don't know if this is my sign that I need to go get a new pair of glasses. Here's what I could read on the piece of paper. Number one, yes, Holly is listed as Utica, good catch. Also her name is listed as Hollis, P-Flax, Jenny O'Keefe is one of the names on the list. Oh, Jenny. She was our second AD.
That's right. I could not tell what branch she was associated with. It was too blurry for me. But Nick Carbone, Nick our boom operator, was listed as the Buffalo branch HR representative and Debbie Pierce from Hair and Makeup, Debbie did hair. Debbie was listed as the Nashua branch HR representative. And then when there were three more names, I could not make out their last names or their branches, but they were Shelly, Kim and Chris.
We had several people with those names and I could not make out the last names. But good catch, Alice. That was really fun for me to see all those names on that sheet and that's who they were. I love that. I love how set dressing would put the names of our crew all over the set. I know. Well, Jenna, I had to know what a hardboiled detective was. Oh, okay.
I mean, especially if we're going to be mom detectives, I feel like I need to know the genre. Yeah. So this is what it says on the internet. It's a literary genre that shares some of its characters and settings with crime fiction, especially detective fiction, our noir fiction. And hardboiled means to be devoid of sentimentality, tough, being a detective, our story featuring a tough, unsynominal protagonist, a matter of fact attitudes towards violence, hardheaded
and practical. Oh, very un-Toby like. Yeah. To be a hardboiled detective, this is like Toby's version of being a superhero. That's right. Wow. I know. Well, now Michael is going to interrupt Jim's meeting with David Wallace.
He's just going to burst into the conference room while on the phone. I have his fake phone call conversations. Please. His first one as he walks in, he says, uh-huh, uh-huh. Well, if he doesn't like it, you can tell that SOB that he's fired. Sorry, I'm going into a meeting right now. I will. See you too.
Bye. Who's he talking to? Who's he talking to? And when he leaves, this is his other fake phone call. Oh, this, um, call waiting. Yeah. Uh-huh. Well, you tell the mayor he just lost six votes.
This tactic of bursting into the room, talking on the phone, reminded me a little bit of my strategy of walking up to famous people laughing. I have to say, I thought maybe. This is Michael's way into a meeting. Yeah. Meeting people. So now Creed and Michael are sort of peering into the conference room together from some file cabinets.
First of all, Creed just always makes me laugh. I love him. I love every time he is on screen. What I also love about the character Creed is that he is the last person you ever want to make you feel better about a situation. True. I know. The fact that they partnered him next to Michael while Michael is worried about what's happening
in the conference room is so perfect. During this, Steve is flipping through the yellow pages. Oh, no. What'd you see? Do you remember the yellow pages? Of course. You used to get a big one in the mail. Yeah.
in the conference room is so perfect. During this, Steve is flipping through the yellow pages. Oh, no. What's you see? Do you remember the yellow pages? Of course. You used to get a big one in the mail. Yeah.
Does this happen anymore? I think the yellow pages are online now, but I think in some places they still print them. Yeah. You still get a hard copy, I think. No, I don't get one. I feel like I got one a few years ago. I don't know.
Do youngins know what the yellow pages are? Let your fingers do the walking. Do they know? I doubt it. You know what? We should show our kids a yellow page. Here, guys, for any of you out there who are young and are like, what are the yellow pages?
So every year you would get a phone book. First of all, you would get white pages and that would list and name and address. Yeah. You would get like an alphabetical list of everyone in your city. And I remember getting it as a kid and like looking us up and being like, there we are. Ours always had like a little star or circle by someone we knew, like my mom would have gone through and like made little markings. Oh, yeah.
Or your market. Yeah. Well, the yellow pages was a directory of all of the businesses in your area and they were listed alphabetically by the type of business. Right. Like florist. Yes, if you needed an electrician, you looked in the electrician section and different businesses might take out ads so that their listing was bigger or flashier, like a half page.
Yeah. And that's why a lot of businesses would put the letter A somewhere in the name. Like awesome plumbers because then they would be at the top of the list. Yes. And then there were also the blue pages, which is a government directory. I never got a blue page. I never heard of the blue pages. Well, they could be at your library.
Oh. You could look in the blue pages if you needed to contact a government agency in your area. Like the water department for your city. Yes. But when I saw the yellow pages, I got really nostalgic and I was like, as a kid, I would flip through the yellow pages and look at the ads. Like, I would read the comics in the newspaper that we got every day at our house and the funnies.
The funnies. And like, I would read the back of the cereal box at breakfast because we didn't have smartphones or internet. Right. I would flip through the Sears catalog circling stuff. Oh, how great was it to get a catalog? I love a catalog. I still love a catalog.
I do still love a catalog. Anyway, well, there you go for you, young ins, all the fun you missed out on. Anytime you want a breakdown of some old tech, just hit up these two middle-aged ladies. We'll tell you. Oh. Now we have Pam's storyline. Yes. She's on the hunt for the RSVPs.
She starts with Kelly. Kelly wants to know if Ryan is going to the wedding. She doesn't want to RSVP unless Ryan is going. Because it would be a waste of time. I mean, wait, that came out wrong. Right. I mean, what she's trying to say is that she would really like it if Ryan went because then she would go and she'd really like to be there to support Jim.
Everything she said to you was like, it's a frenemy moment. We had a fan question from Heather Bee in Victoria, British Columbia. At five minutes, 48 seconds, when Pam goes to Kelly's desk, there is a sign that says Kelly's nook. And there is. And before, she had her little name plate that said Kelly that she got in the Yankee swap. But this is a new sign.
It says Kelly's nook. I love a nook. Heather Bee wondered if this was an addition from the scene when she told Dwight to get out of her nook. Well, this scene is going to take us to a Pam talking head. And Pam and Jim have clearly done that thing. The destination wedding, you guys, if your friend has a destination wedding, it's because they're trying to rule out some people.
I think that's true because you're allowed to have a smaller guest list if it's a destination wedding. That's right. I'm going to go with you to like a remote area or like a fancy vacation. I'm getting married on a boat. What? Well, it is revealed that Jim and Pam are getting married in Niagara Falls. Now, when we traded emails with Warren and Halstead about their episode Cafe Disco, Halstead
reminded me that in an earlier version of the script, Pam and Jim were going to get married in Paris. Oh my gosh. I forgot that. Isn't that crazy? And they changed it to Niagara because they felt like Paris, number one, they thought it was a little bit too kind of on the nose romantic, maybe too much of a stretch budget wise. And they thought Niagara Falls was perfect.
I agree. I think that Paris just seems a little too big and too far away for who Jim and Pam are. I agree. Now, also speaking of Niagara Falls, we are not that far from these wedding episodes. And Randy shared with us that they were already heavily prepping that episode, like heavily. It's a big episode. We'll get there, but it's a big one. At six minutes 32 seconds, we got a fan question from Emily B in Alabama who said, behind Pam
我同意。我觉得对于吉姆和帕姆的性格来说，巴黎似乎有点太大、太远了。我同意。另外，说到尼亚加拉大瀑布，我们离这些婚礼剧集也不远了。兰迪跟我们分享说，他们已经在为那一集做大量准备工作了，真的是下了大功夫。这是一集很重的戏。我们到时候会聊到的，但这一集确实分量很重。在第六分钟32秒，我们收到了来自阿拉巴马州埃米利·B的粉丝提问，她说，在帕姆身后
on the file cabinet by Kelly's desk, there is a greater Scranton Chamber of Commerce business card from someone named Mary. I looked up the current board of directors and apparently this person is no longer active, but I'm curious to know why were they represented on the show. Emily B, Mary at the Chamber of Commerce was like a huge help to our show. Yes, she's an unsung hero. Carrie Bennett shared all about her with us. Yeah.
凯莉办公桌旁的文件柜上，有一张来自一个叫玛丽的人的大斯克兰顿商会名片。我查了一下现任董事会成员，显然这个人已经不在职了，但我很好奇为什么剧中会出现她的名字。埃米利·B，商会的玛丽对我们的节目帮助太大了。没错，她是一位默默无闻的英雄。凯莉·贝内特跟我们分享了关于她的全部故事。是的。
If you remember in Carrie Bennett's interview, it was from a revisited episode. Carrie shared that she created a relationship with Mary and Mary would help us get local treasures for the show, props, signs, pizza boxes. That is a great interview, by the way. If you guys haven't listened to it, our interview with Carrie Bennett, who was the wardrobe designer for the office for the first four seasons, and she really was groundbreaking in what she brought to the show. And the relationship with Mary was one of those things.
如果你还记得凯莉·贝内特的采访，那是来自一集回顾特辑。凯莉分享说她和玛丽建立了一种关系，玛丽会帮我们为节目找到当地的宝藏物件、道具、招牌、披萨盒。顺便说一句，那是一次非常棒的采访。如果你们还没听过，不妨听听我们对凯莉·贝内特的采访，她在前四季担任《办公室》的服装设计师，她在节目中带来的一切真的是具有突破性的。而与玛丽的关系就是其中之一。
But we put that business card in a nice, prominent spot. Yay. I love putting Mary on the show. Yay, Mary. So now we get to one of my favorite scenes. It's Michael sitting on Andy's desk while he's trying to spy on Jim and David's meeting in the conference room, and he's just like throwing out random questions. Oh, lady, I have so much for this.
但我们将这张名片放在了一个非常显眼的好位置。耶。我喜欢把玛丽加入到节目中。耶，玛丽。现在我们要聊到我最喜欢的场景之一了。迈克尔坐在安迪的办公桌上，而安迪正试图偷听吉姆和大卫在会议室里的会面，迈克尔就一直在那儿抛出各种随机的问题。哦，天哪，关于这个我能聊的可太多了。
Are you ready? Yes. I love the scene. I know you loved it. In the episode, it starts with these two lines. Andy says, what can I do for you, Haas? And Michael, staring into the conference room, says, how are your cells doing? But Jenna, the scene was so much bigger, and big chunks of it were edited out for time,
你准备好了吗？准备好了。我超爱这个场景。我知道你也喜欢。在剧中，它是从这两句台词开始的。安迪说：“有什么需要我效劳的吗，哈斯？”而迈克尔盯着会议室说：“你的细胞最近怎么样？”但是，珍娜，这个场景原本要宏大得多，其中有很大一部分为了时长而被剪掉了，
and I feel like we need to hear the full scene. I cannot believe there was more to one of my favorite scenes, and I cannot wait. So much more. All right. So Andy and Michael have this exchange, and then, right after that, this would have happened. Are my cells done? They're good. Super solid.
我觉得我们有必要听听完整的场景。我简直不敢相信我最喜欢的场景之一竟然还有更多内容，我等不及要听了。还有多得多呢。好。所以安迪和迈克尔有这样一段对话，然后，紧接着，本来会发生这些。我的细胞完成了吗？它们很好。超级结实。
What do you mean? Your retention. How's that? How's your retention, Ben? Client retention? You're asking me about client retention? Yes. Why?
你什么意思？你的留存率。那个怎么样？你的客户留存率怎么样，本？客户留存率？你问我客户留存率？对。为什么？
Angela, my sales numbers are not updated, so that's on you. Stop haranguing me. Stop haranging me, all right? So Angela's like, stop haranging me. And then here's the part that made it in. Andy's like, busted. My numbers are down a little bit. It's because of the economy.
安吉拉，我的销售数字还没更新，所以这得怪你。别跟我唠叨了。别跟我唠叨了，行吧？所以安吉拉的反应就像是，别唠叨我了。然后就是播出来的部分。安迪说：“露馅了。我的数字稍微有点下降。这是经济原因造成的。”
You're not buying it. You're good. Okay, the truth is, I've been having trouble focusing lately. I'm in this weird, flirty, nebulous thing with his cousin of mine. It's a total mind effort, which leads to one of my favorite lines, Phyllis saying, again, with the cousin. It's so amazing, the idea that Andy will not shut up about this weird cousin thing, but then he reads the email.
你可不买账。你很懂嘛。好吧，实话实说，我最近很难集中注意力。我和我表妹之间陷入了一种诡异、暧昧、不清不楚的关系。这简直太折磨脑子了，这就引出了我最喜欢的台词之一，菲利斯说：“怎么又是表妹。”这太绝了，安迪居然对这个诡异的表妹事情喋喋不休，但接着他读起了邮件。
Yes. He says, oh, I'm sorry, Phyllis. You explained this email. Okay. Hey, Andy, let's go visit grandma and they get drunk together. Ha-ha. I mean, that's amazing. Okay.
没错。他说，哦，对不起，菲利斯。你来解释一下这封电子邮件。好吧。嘿，安迪，我们去看奶奶吧，然后他们一起喝醉了。哈哈。我的意思是，这太绝了。好吧。
So what aired, it would have stopped there, but the scene keeps going. And this next part, I call Angela coming in hot. Oh. I'll tell you the problem. The problem is that I'm backlogged because Michael hasn't signed off on any of the billing rates for the Buffalo client. Please, I'm trying to figure out what's going on in there. Okay.
所以播出的部分到这里就结束了，但场景还在继续。接下来这一部分，我称之为“安吉拉气势汹汹地登场”。哦。我来告诉你问题所在。问题是我的工作积压了，因为迈克尔还没有签署布法罗客户的任何计费标准。拜访一下，我正试图弄清楚里面在搞什么鬼。好吧。
They're probably talking about what a terrible job you're doing. You know what? I bet they're worried about how you're managing this branch. I know. I emailed David about it. Whoa. I know. I know.
他们可能在讨论你工作做得有多烂。你知道吗？我打赌他们正在担心你是怎么管理这个分公司的。我懂。我为此给大卫发了邮件。哇。我知道。我知道。
And then this moment leads to Michael and Andy hatching a plan. I need to find a way to get in there. I need to fix this branch, but first I need to get into that room. Check this out. I put together a cheese cart, hide you underneath, roll you in, all of a sudden, blammo, you can hear everything going on. I'm the branch manager. I'm not hiding underneath the cheese cart.
然后这个时刻促使迈克尔和安迪谋划了一个计划。我得想办法进去。我得修复这个分公司，但首先我得进到那个房间里。你看这个。我准备了一辆奶酪推车，把你藏在下面，把你推进去，然后突然间，砰，你能听到里面发生的一切。我是分公司经理。我才不藏在奶酪推车下面。
As the branch manager, I used to garner respect. No, I gotta think of something else. Think something with dignity, okay? Caviar cart. Caviar cart, something with dignity. I'll do the cart. I'll hide it in a cart. Yeah, no problem.
作为分公司经理，我以前可是备受尊重的。不，我得想点别的。想一个有尊严点的，好吗？鱼子酱推车。鱼子酱推车，得有点尊严。我来坐这个推车。我会把自己藏在推车里。对，没问题。
You can wheel me in, but make it classy. Please. Oh, wow. Now, I have to say I miss the stuff with Angela because I think that that would get in Michael's head in such a way that it's his motivation for doing something so extreme as the cheese cart. Well, it heightens everything. It does.
你可以把我推进去，但一定要显得高档一点。拜访。哦，哇。现在，我必须说我很怀念安吉拉的那些戏份，因为我觉得那会深深地钻进迈克尔的脑子里，成为他做出像奶酪推车这样极端行为的动力。嗯，这把一切都推向了高潮。确实如此。
But at the same time, I like that they cut out the discussion of the cheese cart because that is such a funny reveal after the commercial. Yeah. Well, I think we should take a break. And then when we come back, it'll be all cheese cart. Oh, yeah. And we're going to learn something new about Andy in a deleted scene. We are back.
但与此同时，我喜欢他们删掉了关于奶酪推车的讨论，因为在广告之后，那个揭晓实在是太搞笑了。对。嗯，我觉得我们应该休息一下。然后等我们回来，全都是奶酪推车。哦，是的。我们还将在一个删减片段中了解到关于安迪的新内容。我们回来了。
And you know what they say about a plan when it's just so crazy, it might work. Yeah. Operation cheese cart. It's happening. You know why? It's just elegant. We have his talking head in the kitchen and over Michael's shoulder. We can see Andy preparing a cheese cart.
你知道人们是怎么形容一个疯狂到可能会成功的计划的吗？是的。奶酪推车行动。它要进行了。你知道为什么吗？因为它就是这么优雅。我们在厨房里看到了他的单人采访，透过迈克尔的肩膀。我们可以看到安迪正在准备一辆奶酪推车。
He's taking cheese out of some sandwiches. We had a fan catch from Gabby M. in Phoenix who said, when Andy is making the cheese plate, he takes five pieces of cheese off of someone's sandwich. Who puts five pieces of cheese on a sandwich? And I was like, good catch, Gabby. I have an answer for you. What? Remember those eight deleted scenes?
他正在从某些三明治里拿掉奶酪。我们收到了来自菲尼克斯的加比·M的粉丝抓包，她说，安迪在做奶酪拼盘时，从别人的三明治上拿走了五片奶酪。谁会在三明治里放五片奶酪？当时我就想，抓得好，加比。我有一个答案给你。什么？还记得那八个删减片段吗？
Yes. Here's one of them. It would have happened later in the episode. Interior kitchen. Kevin takes a bite out of his sandwich and looks confused. Kevin opens the sandwich and discovers the cheese is missing. Kevin says, hey, and sadly walks to the fridge, takes out the blue cheese dressing and pours it onto his sandwich and starts to eat it.
对。这是其中之一。它本该发生在剧集的晚些时候。室内厨房。凯文咬了一口他的三明治，看起来很困惑。凯文打开三明治，发现奶酪不见了。凯文说：“嘿。”然后沮丧地走到冰箱前，拿出蓝纹奶酪酱倒在三明治上，开始吃起来。
It was Kevin's sandwich. He likes a lot of cheese. Gabby, Kevin likes five pieces of cheese. That's who. Now we realize that Michael is going to hide in the bottom of this cheese cart. Gabby wheels him into the conference room and gives a big old speech about cheese. I mean, it's a fantastic speech. We had a fan question from Christie R. in Greensboro, North Carolina.
那是凯文的三明治。他喜欢很多奶酪。加比，凯文就是喜欢五片奶酪。就是这样。现在我们意识到迈克尔将藏在这个奶酪推车的底部。加比把他推到会议室里，发表了一大段关于奶酪的演讲。我的意思是，这是一场精彩绝伦的演讲。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州格林斯博罗的克里斯蒂·R的粉丝提问。
And I'm just going to say, Christie R., you are reading my mind. What is it, Christie? Andy's cheese tray explanation is one of my favorite scenes. Was any part of this improvised? Were there any alts, him talking about how the cheddar-style spread has reacted nicely with the air makes me laugh out loud every time. Christie, me too. Same.
我想说的是，克里斯蒂·R，你简直是在读我的心。是什么，克里斯蒂？安迪对奶酪盘的解释是我最喜欢的场景之一。这里面有任何即兴发挥的部分吗？有什么备选台词吗？他谈到切达干酪风格的抹酱如何与空气完美结合，每次都逗得我哈哈大笑。克里斯蒂，我也是。一样。
Can we hear it? We have to. We have to hear it. I need to hear him say challenging and delicious. Oui, oui, monsieur. From the Wisconsin region, a nice, firm cheddar. Also from the great state of Wisconsin, an aged parmesan. Here you will find a cheddar-style spread, which has reacted nicely with the air to form
我们能听听吗？我们必须听。我们一定要听。我需要听他说“具有挑战性”和“美味”。Oui, oui, monsieur。来自威斯康星州，一种优质、紧实的切达干酪。同样来自伟大的威斯康星州，一种陈年帕玛森干酪。在这里你会发现一种切达干酪风格的抹酱，它与空气产生了美妙的反应，形成了一层
a light rind, which I think you'll find both challenging and delicious. At that point, I would recommend you take a quick trip south of the border to the great state of Illinois, where you will find this fine blue cheese dressing. If I may be so bold, it's a lot of fun to let the goldfish take a little swim in the blue cheese. Bon appetit. Okay. I checked the script and the line, which has reacted nicely with the air to form a light
轻薄的外皮，我想你会觉得它既具有挑战性又很美味。在那之后，我建议你往南去一趟，前往伟大的伊利诺伊州，在那里你会找到这款优质的蓝纹奶酪酱。如果我可以大胆一点的话，让金鱼饼干在蓝纹奶酪里游个泳，其实是一件非常有趣的事。祝您用餐愉快。好吧。我查了剧本，那句“与空气产生了美妙的反应，形成了一层轻薄的外皮，我想你会觉得它既具有挑战性又很美味”
rind that I think you'll find both challenging and delicious, was not in there. Also the scripted version did not include the part about the goldfish going for a swim in the blue cheese. I do not know if Ed improvised these things, if they pitched him these lines on the fly, but I also think I can kind of almost hear Ed breaking at the beginning of this cheese speech because I just know his voice so well. And I have to imagine there are bloopers. I have to imagine.
并不在剧本里。而且剧本里也没有包含关于金鱼饼干去蓝纹奶酪里游泳的那部分。我不知道这些是不是艾德即兴发挥的，还是当时有人现场塞给他这些台词，但我也觉得，由于我对他的声音太熟悉了，我几乎能听出艾德在这段奶酪演讲开始时差点笑场。我敢说肯定有NG镜头。我敢肯定。
I have not seen them. They are not on the blooper reel, but I don't know. You know there were bloopers. Come on. Him and John in the same room together and him saying all that stuff, forget it. Also we had a fan catch from Sessia Z in London, Ontario, Canada. If you look closely at eight minutes, 55 seconds, you can see Michael peeking out of the sheet from the cheese platter cart.
我还没看过。它们不在NG花絮里，但我不知道。你明明知道肯定有NG。拜托。他和约翰在同一个房间里，他说出那些乱七八糟的东西，别想了。此外，我们还收到了来自安大略省伦敦市的塞西亚·Z的粉丝抓包。如果你仔细看第八分钟55秒，你可以看到迈克尔从奶酪拼盘推车的床单里探出了头。
And you can. It is amazing. It's as Andy is leaving. Michael just like peeks out the corner because I thought to myself, did they make Steve really sit in that cheese cart for all of that? I think he was in there. I think he was because what if he did something and they wanted it on camera? You never know with Steve, right?
确实能看到。这太绝了。就在安迪离开的时候。迈克尔只是探出了个角，因为我当时在想，他们真的让史蒂夫在那辆奶酪推车里坐了那么久吗？我觉得他在里面。我觉得他在，因为如果他做了什么动作而他们想要拍下来呢？你永远猜不透史蒂夫，对吧？
Well, you know what it reminded me of? It reminded me of the time that I was on busy Phillips talk show and it was my birthday and busy was giving me all these presents one by one from cast members of the office. What did I give you? You gave me a t-shirt with a picture of bread on it. I believe Ellie sent me a jar of rosemary crackers. Yes, she did. We'll tell you all about that in the finale episode.
嗯，你知道这让我想起了什么吗？这让我想起了我有一次上忙碌·菲利普斯的脱口秀，那天是我的生日，忙碌一个接一个地送给我这些礼物，都是《办公室》的演员送的。我送了你什么？你送了我一件印有面包图片的T恤。我记得艾伊送了我一罐迷迭香饼干。没错，她确实送了。我们在大结局那一集会把所有这些都告诉你。
You're going to have to wait for it. But there was this giant box on the stage and that was the final gift. What was it? What was this box going to be? Can I point out it was on the stage for like 20 minutes. A long time. Yeah. A very long time.
你们得拭目以待了。但舞台上有一个巨大的箱子，那是最后的礼物。那是什么？这个箱子到底会是什么？我得指出的是，它在舞台上呆了大约20分钟。很长时间。是的。非常长的时间。
And I was like going on and on about sourdough starter all the while this big box is sitting there and after 20, 30 minutes of this taping, Steve Carell popped out of the box. Yeah. And I was like, there's one more gift and poor Steve had been sitting in a box for half an hour. But who knows how long he'd been there because he probably had to crawl in it before you came out on stage. Well, busy did this whole crazy thing during the break where she was like, Jenna, come
我一直在喋喋不休地谈论酸面团酵种，而这个大箱子就一直摆在那里，在录制了20、30分钟之后，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔突然从箱子里跳了出来。是的。当时我就想，还有一个礼物，而可怜的史蒂夫已经在箱子里坐了半个小时了。但谁知道他在里面呆了多久，因为在你上台之前，他可能就得先进去爬在里面了。好吧，忙碌在休息期间搞了这么一出疯狂的把戏，她说：“珍娜，过来。
here. I want to take a picture with you inside of our photo booth. And I was like, okay. And then we went in there and she was like, oh, it's not working. It's not what you stay in here. Stay in the photo booth while I put it. She was like, guys, you've got to fix the booth and she would not let me out of this photo booth.
我想和你在我们的照相亭里拍张照片。”我说：“好吧。”然后我们进去了，她说：“哦，它坏了。你先待在这儿别动。待在照相亭里，我来弄……”她对大家说：“伙计们，你们得修理这个亭子。”而且她就是不让我离开这个照相亭。
It was so, I remember thinking like, this is odd. She really wants the photo booth picture. I mean, this is very Angela Kinsey of her, but I think that was when Steve was loading into the box. Oh yeah. They were trying to keep you tucked away so you wouldn't see, but I was so surprised and then I think the first thing I said was, how long have you been in there? But anyway, when he was hiding in the cheese cart, I was like, oh my God, that reminds me
当时的感觉是，我记得自己还在想，这太奇怪了。她真的很想要那张照相亭的照片。我的意思是，这非常安吉拉·金斯利，但我想那就是史蒂夫正在被塞进箱子里的时候。哦，是的。他们试图把你藏起来，这样你就看不到了，但我当时太震惊了，然后我想我说的第一句话是：“你在里面呆了多久了？”不管怎样，当他躲在奶酪推车里时，我就想：“哦，天哪，这让我想起了
of when he hid in that box. I must have watched that scene, Jenna, probably five times. I just loved it so much. Same. And I had this moment where I was like, has Ed been a waiter because that was so good. Yeah. Has he served cheese? Has he served cheese or some kind of food?
他躲在那个箱子里的时候。”珍娜，那个场景我大概看了有五遍。我真的太喜欢了。我也是。当时我有种感觉：“艾德难道当过服务员吗？因为这也太专业了吧。”是的。他端过奶酪吗？他端过奶酪或其他什么食物吗？
But we did find some really great new information about Andy in a deleted scene. Jenna, it would have come earlier in the kitchen, but this is why Andy knows so much about cheese. You got to hear it. No, no, no. No. What? You don't put a soft cheese next to a hard cheese. I was making a smiley face.
不过，我们确实在一个删减片段中发现了关于安迪的一些非常棒的新信息。珍娜，它本该早点出现在厨房里，但这就是为什么安迪对奶酪了解得这么多。你得听听这个。不，不，不。不。什么？你不能把软奶酪挨着硬奶酪放。我在做一个笑脸。
Mm-hmm. Okay. Let me ask you something. Did you also spend a summer in Toulouse apprenticing for a firmagier? Hmm? What? Yeah. I didn't think so.
嗯哼。好吧。我问你个事。你是不是也在图卢兹的一个奶酪作坊当过一个夏天的学徒？嗯？什么？对。我就知道没有。
All right. I'm all right. You know a lot about cheeses. I just, I've already started. I'll just, all right. Oh, hey. What do you think I should say if I get caught? First of all, it's a foolproof plan.
好吧。我没事。你对奶酪确实很了解。我只是，我已经开始了。我就，好吧。哦，嘿。如果我被抓了，你觉得我该说些什么？首先，这是一个天衣无缝的计划。
I know. But, uh, something were to happen. What should I say? Cart, cart. I got it. Paul's and me. Do you have any grape poop, Paul? Yes.
我知道。但是，呃，要是真的发生了点什么呢？我该说点什么？推车，推车。我知道了。格雷庞，保罗。你有格雷庞吗，保罗？是的。
I will use the grape poop, Paul. Now I sort of want to get caught. Oh my gosh. Okay. First of all, Andy was a firmagier apprentice. Yeah. Second of all, the grape poop, Paul. Don't you wish that had happened?
我会用格雷庞的，保罗。现在我有点想被抓个正着了。哦，天哪。好吧。首先，安迪竟然是个奶酪学徒。是的。其次，那个格雷庞，保罗。你难道不希望那一幕真的发生吗？
I kind of need it to happen. I totally remember those commercials. I did too. Which sent me down a rabbit hole. Last night, you remember guys, they were a long time ago, but there would be sort of a very elegant refined gentleman in a Rolls-Royce eating an elaborate sandwich with grape poop on in the back seat.
我有点迫切希望它发生。我完全记得那些广告。我也是。这让我陷入了一个深渊。昨晚，你们还记得吧，伙计们，那是很久以前的事了，会有那种非常优雅精致的绅士坐在劳斯莱斯里，在后座上吃着抹了格雷庞芥末酱的精致三明治。
In the back of his car. Yeah. Like on a little mini tray. Yes. Like as if he was on an airplane and like an English countryside and another Rolls-Royce with another older distinguished gentleman would pull up and they would say this. Pardon me.
在他的车后座。是的。就像在一个小托盘上一样。是的。就好像他在飞机上一样，或者在英国乡间，另一辆载着另一位年长尊贵绅士的劳斯莱斯会开过来，然后他们会这样说。打扰一下。
Would you have any grape poop on? But of course. So, of course that wasn't where I stopped Jenna with my grape poop on research. Of course not. I would hope not. I had to go to the grape poop on website and there's a lot of fascinating things about grape poop on.
你有格雷庞吗？但当然有啦。所以，我当然没有停下对格雷庞的研究，珍娜。当然没有。我希望没有。我不得不去浏览格雷庞的网站，上面有很多关于格雷庞的迷人知识。
Did you know it was made with wine? No. Yes. And not only that. Did you know that grape poop on made a wine? Wait. What? Yes.
你知道它是用葡萄酒做的吗？不知道。是的。不仅如此。你知道格雷庞还出过一款葡萄酒吗？等等。什么？是的。
They're a winemaker and a fancy mustard maker? They make fancy mustard but they decided to feature a white wine. It was called La Moutarde Vin. Probably saying it wrong. And it was inspired by their grape poop on mustard. Here is how the wine is described Jenna. Are you ready?
他们既是酿酒师又是高级芥末制造商？他们制作高级芥末，但他们决定推出一款白葡萄酒。它叫拉穆塔尔·文。我可能发音不对。它的灵感来自于他们的格雷庞芥末酱。以下是这款酒的描述，珍娜。你准备好了吗？
Yes. Bright hints of spice, pronounced citrus, floral characteristics balanced by vibrant acidity with the typical texture and roundness on the palate you'd expect from a vignere. Probably saying that wrong. So guess what? What?
是的。明亮的香料气息，明显的柑橘和花香特征，伴随着充满活力的酸度，以及你在酿酒师那里所期望的典型的口感和圆润度。我可能发音不对。所以你猜怎么着？什么？
I thought we both needed a bottle. What? What? And I tried to buy the grape poop on white wine and it sold out. Oh my God. I am going to tell you right now that I have never in my life craved more a sandwich with grape poop on mustard and a glass
我觉得我们俩都需要来上一瓶。什么？什么？我试图买格雷庞的白葡萄酒，结果卖光了。哦，天哪。我现在就告诉你们，我这辈子从来没有这么渴望过一个抹了格雷庞芥末酱的三明治，以及一杯他们的芥末葡萄酒。什么？我现在就要。
of their mustard wine. What? I need it now. Well, I'm going to keep trying to buy it. You had me so excited and now I am so sad. I'm going to keep trying to buy it because even as I read the description of the white wine inspired by grape poop on mustard.
好吧，我会继续试着买的。你让我这么激动，现在我却这么难过。我还是会试着买，因为当我宣读那款灵感来自格雷庞芥末酱的白葡萄酒的描述时。
Yes. It sounded like Andy describing the cheese cart. I mean with a typical texture and roundness on the palate. Wow. And that wraps up the cheese cart, deleted scene runner. I'd like to share with everyone for you, Angela, that you love cheese. I love cheese.
是的。听起来就像安迪在描述奶酪推车。我是说，带有典型的口感和圆润度。哇。奶酪推车删减片段串联到此结束。安吉拉，我想跟大家分享一下，你很喜欢奶酪。我喜欢奶酪。
When we went out to dinner in New York where we were celebrating our billboard in Times Square. 200 million downloads. So amazing. We went to dinner and on the menu one of the options is a cheese plate with fancy cheeses. Yes. Several different kinds you can pick.
我们在纽约共进晚餐时，当时我们在时代广场庆祝我们的巨幅广告牌。2亿次下载。太惊人了。我们去吃晚饭，菜单上的选项之一就是带有高级奶酪的奶酪拼盘。是的。你可以挑选几种不同的种类。
And this is Angela reading the menu. I'm going to be Angela reading the menu. Well, I definitely want cheese. I don't know what else I want, but I'm going to need to get cheese. What do you want to start? Do you want some cheeses? I want some cheeses.
这是安吉拉在读菜单。我要扮演安吉拉读菜单。嗯，我绝对想要奶酪。我不知道我还想要什么，但我必须得来点奶酪。你想从什么开始？你想来点奶酪吗？我想来点奶酪。
I don't know. Then you were like, should we have cheeses after? I said, how about cheeses like a dessert course? Yeah. Because we were hungry and we wanted a bunch of food. Yeah. And I said, why don't we see how we feel at the end? And maybe we get cheese as dessert and wine.
我不知道。然后你说，我们应该在之后吃奶酪吗？我说，把奶酪当成甜点怎么样？对。因为我们当时很饿，想吃很多东西。是的。然后我说，不如我们看看最后感觉怎么样。也许我们可以把奶酪当作甜点和酒。
They do it in Europe, right? Right. You end with cheese. Right. Well, we ate and the restaurant was so kind to us. They brought us an extra appetizer on the house. They were Office Ladies fans. Yeah.
他们在欧洲就是这么做的，对吧？对。以奶酪收尾。对。好吧，我们吃了，而且那家餐厅对我们太好了。他们免费送了我们一道额外的开胃菜。他们是《办公室女士》的粉丝。是的。
And then we had big hearty pasta. We were too full for cheese. And I watched Angela get real sad when she realized that she would not be ordering cheese. This woman loves cheese. I love cheese. I love all kinds of cheese. I once bought a super stinky cheese that my family asked me
然后我们吃了丰盛浓郁的意大利面。我们饱得吃不下奶酪了。我看着安吉拉意识到自己点不了奶酪时，整个人变得好伤心。这个女人太爱奶酪了。我喜欢奶酪。我喜欢各种各样的奶酪。我曾经买过一种超级臭的奶酪，我的家人要求我
to put in the garage because it had stunk up our fridge so bad. And when I would take it out to eat it, literally the kids were like, ugh. All right, guys, we got a little off topic. Who, us? No. But forgive us. It was cheese.
把它放进车库里，因为它把我们的冰箱熏得太臭了。当我把它拿出来吃的时候，孩子们真的会说，呃。好吧，伙计们，我们有点跑题了。谁，我们？没有。但请原谅我们。那是奶酪。
If anything's going to take us off topic, it's going to be cheese. Cheese. And then when you find out a fancy mustard made of wine, come on. I mean, it was inevitable. At the end of this scene, though, David Wallace is going to leave the conference room.
如果有什么能让我们跑题的话，那肯定就是奶酪了。奶酪。然后当你发现还有用葡萄酒做的高级芥末时，拜托。我的意思是，这是不可避免的。不过，在这场戏的最后，大卫·华尔士要离开会议室了。
And Michael is going to wheel himself out of the office. With one foot. Steve really did that. It's amazing. And then Wallace is going to say, can we have a chat in your office? That's going to pay off in a little bit. But first, Toby and Dwight are on a stake out at Darrell's
而迈克尔将在吉姆面前把自己滑出办公室。只用一只脚。史蒂夫真的做到了。这太绝了。然后华尔士会说，我们能在你办公室聊聊吗？这会在一会儿得到回报。但首先，托比和德怀特在达瑞尔家外面监视。
house. Yeah. And I have a question for my train aficionados out there. Yeah. Does this train lingo track? See what I did there? Does the train lingo track? Hey, that is, that's like dad level pun right there.
对。我有一个问题要问我身边的火车迷们。对。这段火车行话对不对得上？看我现学现卖。这段火车行话对得准吗？嘿，这简直就是老爸级别双关语。
I know. Dad pun. Dad pun. Yeah. Because I'll tell you why. Toby says, sounds like an EMD P40. Dwight says, now that's a GE. A P40 is much higher pitched.
我知道。老爸双关。老爸双关。是的。因为我来告诉你为什么。托比说：“听起来像个EMD P40。”德怀特说：“那明明是个GE。P40的音调要高得多。”
So I looked all that up. I couldn't find anything called an EMD P40. I did find a six axle passenger diesel electric locomotive built by General Motors Electromotive Division called an EMD SD P40. Okay. But we saw a picture of the train and it was not a passenger train. That's right. And GE does make locomotives for freight trains.
所以我把这些都查了一遍。我找不到任何叫EMD P40的东西。我确实找到了由通用汽车电气化分公司制造的六轴客运柴油电力机车，叫做EMD SD P40。好吧。但我们看到了火车的照片，它根本不是一辆客运列车。没错。而且GE确实为货运列车制造机车。
They're a leading manufacturer. So maybe Dwight was right. I don't know guys. My train people is this accurate. I just love that Dwight is able to differentiate trains by the sound of the train horn. By the pitch. Yeah.
它们是领先的制造商。所以也许德怀特是对的。我不知道，伙计们，我的火车专家们，这准确吗？我只是觉得德怀特能通过火车喇叭的声音分辨出不同的火车，这太酷了。通过音高。是的。
That's kind of amazing. Train people, let us know. Is this accurate? Well, here's what's going to happen on their stakeout. Oh my gosh. They see Daryl not on crutches walking with a giant bag of dog food on his shoulder. Right.
这简直太神奇了。火车迷们，让我们知道一下。这准确吗？好吧，接下来在他们的监视中会发生这样的事。哦，天哪。他们看到达瑞尔没有拄拐杖，而是扛着一大袋狗粮在走路。对。
Same jersey walking from behind. Can't see his face. They're positive it's him. Guess what? That's not him. It's his sister. It is. But they've already shouted and revealed themselves to be like on the
穿着同样的球衣从后面走来。看不到他的脸。他们确信那就是他。你猜怎么着？那不是他。那是他姐姐。确实是。但他们已经大喊大叫并暴露了自己正在
stakeout and then they peel away and they run into some trash cans. Oh no. They make total asses of themselves and they're completely busted. Well, location alert. We shot this scene on Emelida Street in Van Nuys, California. Phil Shea created that enormous dog food bag using a fictional label created by our graphics designer, Ryan Cosgrove. And it was our stunt coordinator, Sean Crowder, who was doubled for Dwight
监视，然后他们掉头就跑，一头撞进了几个垃圾桶里。哦，不。他们彻底出了丑，并且完全被抓包了。好吧，外景警报。我们在加利福尼亚州范奈斯的埃梅利达街拍摄了这个场景。菲尔·谢伊利用我们的平面设计师瑞安·科斯格罗夫创作的虚构标签，制作了那个巨大的狗粮袋。我们的特技协调员肖恩·克劳德替身德怀特
driving into the trash cans. They also had a stunt double for Toby in that scene. And I looked at it. It's amazing. Like, could you tell? No. I didn't catch it. I could not tell, but the stunt person who was playing Toby does this
开车撞进垃圾桶。那个场景中他们还为托比找了一个特技替身。我看过了。太绝了。比如，你能看出来吗？不能。我没看出来。我看不出来，但扮演托比的特技演员在那个场景中做了一个
like really hardcore like jerk forward. And so later when Toby is like icing his forehead, like clearly that was like Ryan that was tracked. But it's good. It was a good stunt. I think we should title this next scene too cool for school in the break room. Yeah.
非常硬核的向前猛冲动作。所以后来当托比在冰敷额头时，很明显那是瑞安被追踪到了。但这很好。这是一个很好的特技。我觉得我们应该把下一场戏命名为休息室里的“优等生”。是的。
Oh boy. Ryan. Pam is trying to find out if Ryan is coming to the wedding. He's like, yeah, I might stop by. And Pam's like, I might stop by. This is a wedding, Ryan. I know. There's no might stop by.
哦，天哪。瑞安。帕姆正试图弄清楚瑞安是否会去参加婚礼。他说：“是啊，我可能会顺便过去。”帕姆的反应是：“我可能会顺便过去？这是一场婚礼，瑞安。”我知道。没有什么“可能会顺便过去”。
Pam is like, it's $75 a plate. So I kind of need a solid answer. And Ryan's like, oh, I once drank a 77 glass of cognac. And, you know, yeah, I'll come to the wedding. Probably. I'll probably come. I have a fun fact. Okay.
帕姆说：“每位75美元呢。所以我需要一个确切的答复。”瑞安却说：“哦，我曾经喝过一杯77美元的干邑白兰地。而且，你知道的，我会去参加婚礼的。可能会去。我可能会去。”我有一个冷知识。好的。
The most expensive bottle of cognac in the world is a bottle of Gaultier cognac from 1962. It's sold at auction for $144,525 in May of 2020. Whose cognac was it? Was it like Da Vinci's cognac? Who had that cognac? Why is it so special? I don't know.
世界上最贵的一瓶干邑白兰地是1962年的戈蒂埃干邑白兰地。它在2020年5月以144,525美元的价格在拍卖会上售出。那是谁的干邑白兰地？那是达芬奇的干邑吗？谁拥有那瓶干邑？为什么它这么特别？我不知道。
But because there are only three bottles of this quote exceedingly rare spirit that still exists today and all of them still have their original labels. So people check your liquor cabinets because if you have one of the other two bottles, you are swimming in $144,525. If your grandfather has an old bottle of cognac wedged in the back that his grandfather gave him, it might be your lottery ticket. Yeah. Well, David and Michael are going to have a scene now where David is basically like,
但因为这种被称为“极其罕见的烈酒”如今只剩下三瓶，而且它们都还保留着原样标签。所以大家检查一下你们的酒柜，如果你有另外两瓶中的一瓶，你就坐拥144,525美元了。如果你的祖父在角落里塞了一瓶他祖父传下来的陈年干邑，那可能就是你的彩票中奖号码了。好吧，大卫和迈克尔现在要有一场戏了，大卫基本上是在说，
Michael, can you handle all these new responsibilities? And also, what do you think about Jim in a leadership role? Yeah. And Michael thinks that Jim would be kind of replacing him or maybe leaving the branch. And so he talks bad about Jim. He calls him the big bird of the office. He shows David Toby's report on Jim, which you know is going to be so petty because Toby's in love with Pam.
迈克尔，你能应付所有这些新职责吗？还有，你觉得吉姆担任领导角色怎么样？是的。而迈克尔认为吉姆会取代他，或者可能会离开这个分公司。所以他说吉姆的坏话。他称吉姆为办公室的大鸟，他向大卫展示了托比对吉姆的报告，你知道这肯定会非常小肚鸡肠，因为托比暗恋着帕姆。
Yeah. And this is clearly an old report because it says Jim spends a lot of time at reception, which we know Pam is no longer at. Well, there was a Jim talking head in the shooting draft that didn't make it in. Yet another one of those deleted scenes, right? This is what Jim would have said. So it turns out Pam's dowry was a bit disappointing. It was mostly just stuffed animals and scrunchies.
是的。而且这显然是一份过时的报告，因为它说吉姆花了很多时间在前台，我们知道帕姆已经不在那儿了。好吧，在拍摄初稿中有一个吉姆的单人采访没有被采用。又是一个删减片段，对吧？吉姆当时会这么说。所以事实证明，帕姆的嫁妆有点让人失望。基本上只是一些毛绒玩具和发圈。
And a kid can't live on scrunchies. The stuffed animals may come in handy. Anyway, yeah, I need a promotion. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Pam's dowry was stuffed animals and scrunchies. You know, what's funny to me about that is that it was Jim who brought the debt into
而一个孩子是靠发圈活不下去的。毛绒玩具倒是可能会派上用场。总之，是的，我需要升职。嗯。嗯。嗯。帕姆的嫁妆是毛绒玩具和发圈。你知道，这件事对我觉得好笑的地方在于，正是吉姆通过购买他父母的房子把债务带入了
their marriage with the purchase of his parents' home. I knew, I knew I was going to stir the pot. I'm just saying. I knew. I'm just saying. I knew when I read it, I would stir the Jim and Pam pot. Well, it was in this scene with David Wallace that I saw all the sticky notes on the computer. And also there's a fan catch from Kane H from California who said in the meeting, Michael
他们的婚姻中。我知道，我知道我要挑起事端了。我只是说说而已。我知道。我只是说说。我当时读到的时候就知道，我会去搅动吉姆和帕姆这锅水。好吧，正是在这场与大卫·华尔士的戏中，我看到了电脑上的所有便签。此外，来自加利福尼亚州的凯恩·H有一个粉丝抓包，他说在会议中，迈克尔
says he has to talk to his guy from H&R Block. But in job fair, Michael says, what does H&R Block do? So has Michael learned what H&R Block does? Or does he just say it to try to be relatable? Well, I like that catch, Kane. And I'm pretty sure that he is using it wrong because he tells David Wallace, he has to talk to his mother and his H&R Block guy about being promoted to all Northeast sales. I'm not sure why you need your guy at H&R Block to weigh in.
说他必须跟他在H&R Block（税务公司）的朋友谈谈。但在招聘会上，迈克尔却说：“H&R Block是做什么的？”所以迈克尔是搞懂了H&R Block是做什么的吗？还是他只是为了显得自己接地气才这么说的？好吧，凯恩，我喜欢这个抓包。而且我深信他用错了地方，因为他告诉大卫·华尔士，他必须跟他的母亲和他在H&R Block的朋友谈谈关于晋升为全东北区销售总监的事。我不太确定为什么你需要找你在H&R Block的朋友来权衡这件事。
I think he should weigh in on everything. I think that's what Michael thinks. Relationship advice. Well, Jim does have a talking head, Angela, where he says that the reason he didn't tell Michael about all of this promotion stuff was that he was afraid Michael would try to help and that it would be a debacle, and he notes that Michael once handed out Jell-O shots at the 23rd mile of the Steamtown Marathon. We got some mail from Greg Zee in Pocono Pines, Pennsylvania.
我觉得他应该对所有事情都发表意见。我想迈克尔就是这么想的。恋爱建议。好吧，吉姆确实有一个单人采访，安吉拉，他在里面说他没有把所有这些晋升的事情告诉迈克尔的原因是，他担心迈克尔会试图帮忙，结果会搞得一团糟，他指出迈克尔曾经在斯蒂姆敦马拉松的第23英里处分发过果冻酒。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州波科诺派恩斯的格雷·Z的一封信。
What's up, Greg? I found this a delightful letter. Greg Zee says, as you two plan your epic road trip to Scranton, Pennsylvania, I propose that you add the Steamtown Marathon to your list of must-dos. In fact, how fun would it be for you two to make an appearance at the 23rd mile of the race, the exact spot where Michael handed out his Jell-O shots? P.S., I am currently training for my 13th Steamtown Marathon myself, and I listen to your podcast every Wednesday or sometimes I save it for my long runs on Sundays.
怎么啦，格雷？我觉得这是一封令人愉快的信。格雷·Z说：“当你们俩计划前往宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的史诗般公路旅行时，我建议你们把斯克兰顿马拉松加入到你们的必做清单中。事实上，你们俩去比赛的第23英里处露面会有多有趣，那正是迈克尔分发果冻酒的准确地点。附言，我目前正在为我个人的第13场斯克兰顿马拉松进行训练，我每周三都会听你们的播客，有时我会把它留到周日长跑时听。”
A lot of people are surprised that I listen to podcasts instead of music while running, but I think a podcast about a show set in Scranton is the perfect listening choice while preparing for a race that ends in Scranton. Oh, Greg, I love that. Greg, I hope you're running right now. Hello. Hello. How's it going? I hope you're hydrated and have really comfortable running shoes.
很多人对我在跑步时听播客而不是听音乐感到惊讶，但我认为，收听一个以斯克兰顿为背景的节目的播客，是在为一场终点设在斯克兰顿的比赛做准备时最完美的收听选择。哦，格雷，我太喜欢这个了。格雷，我希望你现在正在跑步。你好。你好。进展怎么样？我希望你补充了水分并且穿着非常舒适的跑鞋。
Keep going. Keep going. You can do it. Pep Talks by Jen and Angela. Yeah. David's going to ask Jim to walk him to his car. I think this is never a good thing, guys. I think if someone says, hey, can you walk me to my car? They're going to tell you something. Yeah.
坚持下去。坚持下去。你行的。珍娜和安吉拉的加油打气。是的。大卫要请吉姆陪他走到车前。我觉得这绝不是什么好事，伙计们。我觉得如果有人说：“嘿，你能陪我走到车前吗？”他们肯定要对你说点什么了。是的。
Some shiitake is going to go down. Yeah. And when Jim comes back in the office, he's clearly bummed by whatever it is David said to him. Yeah, Michael tries to bring him some jelly beans, and I want you to know he's definitely bummed because at 13 minutes, 50 seconds, he's taken off his jacket, his ambition jacket, as I like to call it. I think his ambition has been deflated. Oh, yeah.
有些不妙的事情要发生了。是的。当吉姆回到办公室时，无论大卫对他说什么，他显然都感到很沮丧。是的，迈克尔试图给他带去一些果冻豆，我想让你们知道他绝对是沮丧透了，因为在第13分钟50秒时，他脱下了他的夹克，我喜欢称之为“雄心夹克”。我觉得他的雄心壮志泄气了。哦，是的。
Ambition jacket. Yeah. So they're going to go into Michael's office. Jim is like, I need to find out what you told David Wallace. I'd also like to point out that as they walk into Michael's office, I still have my binder on my desk that I've been working on. I've been working on that binder all day. And you know what, guys?
雄心夹克。是的。所以他们要走进迈克尔的办公室。吉姆说：“我得搞清楚你对大卫·华尔士说了些什么。”我还想指出的是，当他们走进迈克尔的办公室时，我的办公桌上仍然放着我一直在做的那个文件夹。我一整天都在做那个文件夹。你知道吗，伙计们？
She really did. By the end of this episode, Pam would have had a stellar binder thanks to Jenna. Yeah, I don't know what the binder is about, but it's going to be great. Toby's not looking so good. Dwight is checking his pupils to see if they're dilated. He's got a big red mark on his forehead. Yeah. And Daryl busts in.
她真的做了一整天。到这一集结束时，多亏了珍娜，帕姆将会拥有一个极其出色的文件夹。是的，我不知道这个文件夹是用来干嘛的，但它肯定很棒。托比看起来状态不太好。德怀特正在检查他的瞳孔，看它们是否放大。他额头上有一个巨大的红印。是的。而达瑞尔闯了进来。
And it's like, hey, you called my sister an A-hole. You drove into my trash cans. Yeah. He's checked off. Yeah, Daryl wants to call corporate and file a complaint. Guys, guest star alert, Daryl's sister Gwyneth was played by Jamila Jackson. She is so good. She is so good in this scene.
就像是在说：“嘿，你管我姐叫混蛋。你撞了我的垃圾桶。”是的。他气炸了。是的，达瑞尔想打电话给总公司并提出投诉。伙计们，客串明星警报，达瑞尔的姐姐格温妮丝由贾米拉·杰克逊饰演。她太棒了。她在这一幕里演得太好了。
Perfect. She's going to appear in another episode as well. And Randy Cordray told us that after they cast her, she agreed to let Debbie Pierce cut her hair to match Craig for this role. Well, it really sold it. I mean, that's commitment. That's actor commitment. It is.
完美。她还会在另一集中出现。兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，在选中她之后，她同意让黛比·皮尔斯剪短头发，以便在这个角色中与克雷格的外表相匹配。这真的很到位。我的意思是，这就是敬业。这就是演员的敬业精神。确实如此。
And sometimes you get asked to do that stuff. Yeah. I remember they would put that in the breakdowns for roles if there was like something you needed to do. Like, I don't know, shave your head or grow a beard or dye your hair. Yes. Ducked up brown like I did for haters back off. Yes. I was a full brunette for two years.
有时候你会被要求做那种事。是的。我记得他们在角色的试镜要求里会写上这些，如果有什么你需要做的事情的话。比如，我不知道，剃光头或者留胡子或者染头发。就像我为《 haters back off 》做的那样，把头发染成深棕色。是的。我当了两年彻头彻尾的黑发女郎。
Yep. Freaked my family out. Well, Jamila, thanks for doing that because we loved you as Daryl's sister. Dwight and Toby are going to have to go down to the warehouse. They're going to apologize. But then Dwight notices that some of the other warehouse workers are using the lift to get down from the top of the stairs. Instead of the stairs, they're like crawling through the banister on top of the lift and then going and going down. And Dwight's like, hold on.
是的。把我的家人吓坏了。好吧，贾米拉，谢谢你这么做，因为我们太喜欢你演的达瑞尔的姐姐了。德怀特和托比将不得不去仓库。他们要去道歉。但随后德怀特注意到其他一些仓库员工正在使用升降机从楼梯顶部下来。他们没有走楼梯，而是像爬过升降机顶部的栏杆那样，然后过去，再降下去。德怀特说：“等一下。
I think you hurt your leg using the lift instead of the stairs. And here's my evidence. There's this new piece of wood up there. Right. Dwight is right. Daryl's like, uh, yeah. So Dwight is like, I'm going to file a complaint because Daryl lied. Daryl is like, I'm going to file a complaint because you harassed my sister.
我觉得你是用升降机而不是楼梯把腿弄伤的。这是我的证据。上面有一块新木板。”没错。德怀特是对的。达瑞尔说：“呃，是的。”所以德怀特说：“我要去投诉，因为达瑞尔撒谎了。”达瑞尔说：“我要去投诉，因为你骚扰了我姐姐。”
Toby is like, no paperwork. We're all just going to move on. There's an epic stare down between Daryl, his sister and Dwight. And it ends with Toby at his desk being like, so. Dwight and Daryl decided to file complaints on one another. So now Toby is in a mountain of paperwork with his red like forehead from running into trash cans and his little stuffed doggy. Toby. All right.
托比说：“不要搞什么文书工作了。大家都要向前看。”达瑞尔、他的姐姐和德怀特之间有一场史诗般的对视。最终以托比坐在他的办公桌前结束，他说：“所以。”德怀特和达瑞尔决定互相投诉。所以现在托比陷入了一大堆文书工作中，他的额头因为撞进垃圾桶而红了一大片，手里还拿着他那个小毛绒狗。托比。好吧。
Well, we have one more storyline to wrap up here. Michael is going to call David Wallace in front of Jim and try to both save his own ass and tell David Wallace that he thinks that Jim is a good person for this promotion. Jim makes him put David on speakerphone and he lies at first and says Jim is not there. And then David is like, I want Jim to be there. So he does like this funny little like, oh, he's walking in. Here he is. Oh, hey. Sitting down.
好了，我们这里还有一个剧情线要收尾。迈克尔要在吉姆面前打电话给大卫·华尔士，试图既保住自己的饭碗，又告诉大卫·华尔士他认为吉姆是这个晋升人选的好人选。吉姆让他把大卫调成免提，他一开始撒谎说吉姆不在。然后大卫说：“我希望吉姆也在。”所以他做了一个搞笑的小动作，像是“哦，他走过来了。他在这儿。哦，嘿。坐下了。”
Well, I had to look it up in the script. I wanted to know, did Steve improvise that in the moment? That was in the script. It was so funny. Steve did it so well. But also in the scene, Angela, David says, hey, I talked to Alan and we had this idea that you guys would become like co managers. Michael, you're going to handle like the sort of big picture stuff. Jim, you handle the day to day.
好吧，我得在剧本里查一下。我想知道，那是史蒂夫当时即兴发挥的吗？那是剧本里写好的。太搞笑了。史蒂夫演得太棒了。但在那个场景中，安吉拉，大卫说：“嘿，我跟艾伦谈过了，我们有一个想法，就是你们俩可以成为共同经理。迈克尔，你将负责宏观方面的事情。吉姆，你负责日常运营。”
What do you think? And Michael's like, I don't know. And David's like, listen, this is the only way I could sell it to Alan. Who's Alan? Who is Alan? Who is this guy? Who the hell is Alan? I don't know who Alan is. But Alan's in charge.
你觉得怎么样？迈克尔说：“我不知道。”大卫说：“听着，这是我能向艾伦推销这个方案的唯一办法。”谁是艾伦？艾伦是谁？这人到底是谁？艾伦到底是谁？我不知道艾伦是谁。但艾伦是负责人。
Clearly. We never meet Alan. I've never heard of Alan before. Well, Alan, whoever you are, this isn't going to go well. It's not going to go well, Alan. It's a terrible idea. Terrible idea. We'll see how it goes next week at least.
很显然。我们从未见过艾伦。我以前从未听说过艾伦。好吧，艾伦，不管你是谁，这事不会顺利的。这不会顺利的，艾伦。这是个糟糕的主意。糟糕的主意。至少我们下周看看情况会怎样吧。
It is not going to go well, Alan. Sorry to say. Well, I love this next moment. Dwight is going to burst in to make an announcement, right? Mm-hmm. What he's discovered in the warehouse. But Michael was already making an announcement that he and Jim will now co-manage the Scranton branch. Dwight?
这不会顺利的，艾伦。遗憾的是。好吧，我很喜欢接下来这个时刻。德怀特要闯进来宣布一个消息，对吧？嗯哼。他在仓库里发现了什么。但迈克尔已经在宣布他和吉姆现在将共同管理斯克兰顿分公司了。德怀特？
Dwight looks like someone hit him in the face with a frying pan. He's like, what the F? And then he has a talking head that's just a scream. Like a primal scream. We had a fan question from Winter P from Fort Wayne, Indiana, my birthplace. That's where I was born. How about that? After Jim gets promoted, Dwight has a talking head where he just screams and you can see
德怀特看起来就像被人用平底锅砸了脸一样。他说：“什么鬼？”然后他有一个单人采访，那只是一声尖叫。就像一声原始的呐喊。我们收到了来自印第安纳州韦恩堡的温特·P的粉丝提问，那是我的出生地。那是我的出生地。怎么样？吉姆升职后，德怀特有一个单人采访，他在里面大喊大叫，你可以看到
Creed like jump out of his seat in the background. Was Creed actually startled by the noise? I mean, I have to say it looked like he was. They might have used the very first take. Yeah. I mean, Creed maybe didn't realize how loud rain was going to be. Well, you know, in the shooting draft, that's the last scene. Oh, yeah.
克里德好像在背景里吓得跳了起来。克里德真的是被那个噪音吓到了吗？我的意思是，不得不说看起来确实是。他们可能用了第一条拍摄的素材。是的。我是说，克里德可能没意识到雨声会有多大。好吧，你知道的，在拍摄剧本里，那是最后一个场景。哦，是的。
But in what made it to air, there was this lovely little ending scene between Meredith and Pam and Angela. I loved it. Pam is still trying to get her RSVP list finalized and she asked Meredith. Is she coming? Meredith says Niagara Falls in October. But then, you know, this scene plays out. We discussed it at the top of the show where Meredith doesn't want to return her RSVP card. She'll just text Pam if she wants ribs or not.
但最终播出的版本中，梅雷迪思、帕姆和安吉拉之间有一个非常温馨的小结尾场景。我很喜欢。帕姆还在努力确定她的回复名单，她问了梅雷迪思。她会来吗？梅雷迪思说十月份去尼亚加拉大瀑布。但随后，你知道的，这个场景展开了。我们在节目开头讨论过，梅雷迪思不想归还她的回复卡。如果她想吃排骨或者不想吃，她会直接给帕姆发短信。
And as Meredith leaves, Pam is clearly like frustrated and Angela says rude about Meredith. Pam is so excited. She's like, yes. And she's going to sit down and have a moment with Angela in the break room and maybe vent a little bit. But first she has to move Angela's purse onto the table. Pam, my bag was there. Yeah. There goes their moment.
当梅雷迪思离开时，帕姆明显感到很沮丧，而安吉拉则说梅雷迪思很粗鲁。帕姆非常兴奋。她就像是，太好了。她本来要坐下来和安吉拉在茶水间享受片刻时光，可能还会稍微发泄一下。但首先她得把安吉拉的包移到桌子上。帕姆，我的包就在那儿。好吧。他们的温情时刻就这样没了。
Over. It's done. They're never going to be friends. Well, there you have it, guys. That was the meeting. This week we have a very special episode of Office Ladies with a very special person who we love. Who we love so much that Jenna is talking like this. We have a special person.
结束了。完了。他们永远不可能成为朋友。好了，各位，这就是这次会议。本周我们有一期非常特别的《办公室女士》节目，嘉宾是一位我们非常喜爱的重要人物。我们太爱她了，以至于珍娜说话都变成这样了。我们有一位特别的嘉宾。
Well, he's fascinating. I can't wait for you guys to hear this interview. Have a fantastic week. Thanks for listening to Office Ladies. We're sending you a big, big hug through the microphone thingy. I like it. We'll see you next week. Use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗯，他太迷人了。我迫不及待想让你们听到这次采访。祝大家度过美好的一周。感谢收听《办公室女士》。我们通过麦克风小东西给你们一个大大的拥抱。我喜欢。我们下周见。使用优惠码：Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。